brianna taylor's settlement is amongst
the largest payouts linked to a police
shooting
obviously we saw about we read that the
12 million dollar settlement
with brianna taylor's family is a
historic move for louisville kentucky
but across america
it's the latest financial repercussion
in a police misconduct case
more than six months after taylor was
killed inside her apartment as police
officers executed a no
knock search warrant the city is poised
to pay its highest ever settlement
a city spokeswoman told cnn thoughts
well that's a lot of money for a city
in times like this are there insurance
policies for cities or is this
out of their general fund generally i
think it's out of their general fund i
don't think there's any insurance policy
for actions like i think they're gonna
have an insurance policy but it's gonna
they're gonna
take it regardless okay so 12 million to
her family to her mother
um but the other thing that was attached
to this is that they have to have some
reforms in the police department
especially on the no knock search
warrants so it's gonna bring some
definite change there i mean
if let's just say this there would have
been a lot of unrest if this hadn't
been a favorable settlement like this i
mean a lot of people were watching that
it seems like it's calmed down a little
bit in louisville
so i think it was acceptable i mean just
picture this you're sitting at home
just middle of the night you're in bed
you're with your boyfriend your
girlfriend
boom someone busts in your door plain
clothes
plain clothes busts in your door what do
you do
what do you do what do you mean what do
i do what are you doing jump on who's
there who goes there i'm gonna
protect my girl i'm gonna protect you
exactly yeah so her boyfriend what did
he do
boom he gets his gun he had a legal gun
yeah one shot
like who the hell just came into my
house this is the story
plainclothes police officers no knock
warrant busts in the door
they get fired at boom they start
blasting
they hit brianna taylor eight to ten
times in the stomach
she doesn't have a gun she didn't have a
shot she was an emt becoming a nurse
sitting in bed gets blasted for no
reason boyfriend gets arrested
it basically turns out no he had a legal
right to carry a firearm
someone busts in your house of course
you shoot he walks off he's good
so now he's out cops are not arrested
they're still no big deal there
now this this innocent woman is just
full-on
dead never to be seen again because the
cops [ __ ] up and by the way why did
they go in the house
because they thought it was a drug house
they found no drugs in the house
whatsoever now you have a whole movement
called
say her name say her name you talk about
a
complete f up by the police here i mean
this is
case example number one why you know not
to get all blm black political
why black people are like what the [ __ ]
is this this is ridiculous
so thank god that at least the city of
kentucky or what is this um
louisville louisville has stepped up but
i guarantee you if you ask brianna
taylor's family do you want 12 million
bucks
or your daughter back they'll take their
daughter but you know
the bigger question here is these cops
who
i think we would all agree messed up
here no i mean yeah
okay um should they be arrested
that's the question or at least be held
accountable
there's more to the story than what
you're saying here okay there's more to
and i'm not gonna go into the whole uh
uh uh her background emt was she about
to become one was she getting fired what
she had drugs
i'm not going to go into that part
because there's a lot of speculations on
both sides
what i am going to say is i'm glad this
is happening
meaning i am glad they're paying 12
million dollars i'm glad there is pain
i am glad someone is getting punished
for this
why because everybody else is going to
see that and see that as a standard
meaning
when you're selling a house your house
you want to sell a 4 million the house
next door sells for 1.2 guess what you
can ask for 1.2
okay when you think about
training your cops on how they break
into a house
and you don't train them properly all
you're gonna say is
guys leadership meeting we have to spend
a little bit more time training our
guests because
we cannot afford 12 million dollars yeah
we just cannot
this is this is a form of defunding the
police by the way
this is a form of the budget gets
smaller by the way this is a form of
hiring freeze we're not hiring
mechanically exactly
organically and i actually like it and i
think it sets the precedence to
get some people out there that are a
little bit sloppy with their gun and the
trigger yeah no kidding
i think that needs to happen and i think
it's a very very good example that's
being made
uh these are the kind of things i like
to see i like to see somebody getting
punished for doing something that
uh uh you when uh you cross the line you
shouldn't have done that because it gets
a lot of other people to be
uh having second thoughts about doing uh
things and at the same time
i also hope the person who went and shot
the two deputy sheriffs you know the
the one that shot the compton in compton
i hope he also gets cod because the
reward right now is 150 175
000 i hope he also gets caught and i
hope he also gets
a severe punishment for others to know
that you don't go and shoot cops that
are sitting there just doing their own
thing
you just shoot them up as long as that
example is being made on both sides
on both sides people say you know what
i'm not going to go shoot a cop and you
know what
next time we break into a house let's
kind of follow protocol because one i
could get fired two 12 million dollars
although that's going to be taking place
justice justice was served and uh
unfortunately you can't do anything to
bring the life back because i promise
you the family who loves
the loved ones would exchange the money
for the human being but uh you know at
least 12 million dollars was paid out
for this and it's a good amount
to take care of that family
you